This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。在《回看往事》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难学步》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
欧文斯女士，你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试一次。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast for another episode. Another bonus episode, I should say, welcome.
Hello，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们讨论20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们20多岁意味着什么。以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本期播客的另一个单集。应该说是另一个特别节目，欢迎。
If you are listening to this right now, you are one of my top listeners. You're one of my paid subscribers. I just want to say a huge thank you. I've got you all in one place, all right here. So I just want to say thank you so much for you know, wanting to listen to the sound of my voice multiple times a week. It is, I don't know, a weird feeling, but I'm so, so grateful that you care about this podcast, you care about this show, and you care about what we're trying to do, which is apply psychology, something that can often
如果你现在正在听这个，你就是我最顶级的听众之一。你是我的付费订阅者之一。我只想说一声非常感谢。我把你们都汇聚在一个地方，就在这里。所以我只想说非常感谢你们，你知道的，每周都想听好几次我声音的质感。这是一种，我不知道，很奇怪的感觉，但我非常非常感激你们关心这个播客，关心这个节目，关心我们正在努力做的事情，那就是运用心理学，这通常
seem really inaccessible and distant to every area of our life, every area of our life in our 20s, and hopefully learn something new every week about what we're experiencing, what we go through, and how that interacts with our mental well-being and the psychological processes that underpin it. So I just want to say a huge thank you to all of you who are listening to this episode right now. You guys chose the topic this week as well. We're talking about micro habits. I gave you guys two options on my Instagram. So if you don't follow me there, that's normally where I make the decision about what I want to record this week.
看起来真的很遥远、高不可攀，但我们要把它应用到我们生活的每一个领域，应用到我们20多岁时生活的每一个领域，并且希望每周都能对我们的经历、我们所经历的事情以及这如何与我们的心理健康和支撑它的心理过程相互作用学到新的东西。所以我只想对现在正在收听这一集的你们所有人说声非常感谢。你们这周也选择了这个话题。我们在聊微习惯。我在我的Instagram上给了你们两个选项。所以如果你在那里没有关注我，我通常会在那里决定我本周想录制什么。
And I gave you two options, either a bonus guest episode. or an episode on microhabits. And here we are, you chose right. I'm very excited to be recording this today. And the research was so fascinating. Some of the studies, some of the things that I found out, I was like, this is crazy. Like, I'm learning so much. I also just want to say we hit a huge milestone this week, which was one million listeners.
我给了你两个选择，要么是一集特别嘉宾访谈。要么是一集关于微习惯的节目。我们现在就在这里，你们选对了。我非常高兴今天能录制这个。而且这项研究太迷人了。一些研究，我发现的一些东西，我都觉得，这太疯狂了。就像我学到了太多东西。我还想说，我们本周迎来了另一个巨大的里程碑，那就是一百万听众。
And I honestly still can't, like, fathom that. Like, I genuinely am so, like, honestly. baffled, a bit confused, a bit overwhelmed, to be honest, that there are so many people listening to this show. Like, I started this as like a side project as like a hobby, just to kind of verbalize the things that I was going through and to be able to have an outlet for the research I was doing and the things that I love to talk about with my wonderful friends. Shout out to them, if they're listening, you guys are amazing. And suddenly it has an audience. So it's been really unexpected and I'm so grateful. I think the other thing I've been really worried about is that as this show
老实说，我还是无法想象。老实说，我真的感到，老实说。有点困惑，有点不知所措，说实话，居然有这么多人收听这个节目。我最初把它当作一个副业，一个爱好，只是为了把我的经历用语言表达出来，并为我正在做的研究以及我喜欢和我的好朋友们谈论的事情找到一个出口。向他们致敬，如果他们在听的话，你们太棒了。突然之间它有了受众。所以这真的非常出乎意料，我太感激了。我想我一直非常担心的另一件事是，随着这个节目的
grows, it might become less authentic. That's something that's really been on my mind. What I want to be able to do is continue posting the things that I really want to talk about and that I hope other people want to hear about, not just things that I feel pressure I need to speak on or following trends. I don't know. I just don't want to lose that authenticity. And I think that's why a lot of people listen to this because I don't know I'm someone in my 20s I'm dealing with this stuff as we all are so I don't know some of my fears and anxieties for the for the people who listen to the bonus episodes so take away whatever you want from that but once again thank you for listening let's get into what we're talking about today micro habits it is such a fascinating
不断成长，它可能会变得没那么真实。这真的是我一直放在心上的事情。我希望能继续发布我真正想谈论的事情，并且希望其他人也想听到这些事情，而不仅仅是因为我觉得有压力需要去谈论或者为了追逐潮流。我不知道。我只是不想失去那种真实感。我想这也是为什么很多人听这个节目，因为我不知道，我是一个20多岁的人，我也在处理这些事情，正如我们所有人一样，所以，我不知道，对于收听特别节目的听众来说，这就是我的一些恐惧和焦虑——所以无论如何，从中汲取你想要的吧，但再次感谢你们的收听，让我们进入今天的话题——微习惯，这是一个如此迷人、
fascinating topic. They've become, like the term microhabits has become quite a trendy saying or a trendy term or concept in wellness communities recently. And I think for mostly really, really good reasons. So what they are is they are these small, simple actions that you're able to take every day or integrate into your life really easily that help you achieve big results. They're basically just small habits, micro habits. Sometimes when we think about, you know, big overhauls of our entire lifestyle, it can seem really overwhelming. But we can use micro habits, which are just small actions that we can change day to day to transform, I think, any area, any facet of our lives that we might not be entirely satisfied with by starting really small, by starting from the ground up. and keeping, you know, the end goal in sight,
迷人的话题。它们已经变成，就像“微习惯”这个词最近在健康社区中变成了一个非常时髦的说法、术语或概念。而且我认为绝大多数原因都是非常好的一. 它们是什么呢，它们是那些你每天都能够采取的、或者非常容易融入你生活的微小、简单的行动，能够帮助你取得巨大的成果。它们基本上就是小习惯，微习惯。有时当我们想到，你知道的，对我们的整个生活方式进行重大全面改造时，可能会让人感到不知所措。但我们可以利用微习惯，这只是我们可以逐日改变的小行动，来改造我认为我们可能并非完全满意的生活的任何区域、任何方面，通过从小事做起，从头开始。并且将，你知道的，最终目标保持在视野中，
but making it easier for us to get there and to ease into those changes and those transformations and to ensure that the changes we want to make to our lives are sustainable. You know, there's no point putting a lot of effort into something, putting all your eggs in one basket, dedicating yourself entirely to some goal, if you're going to give up after one month because you're mentally and physically exhausted.
但让我们更容易到达那里，更容易适应这些改变和转型，并确保我们想要对生活进行的改变是可持续的。你知道的，把大量精力投入到某件事上，把所有的鸡蛋放在一个篮子里，全身心地投入到某个目标中，如果你一个月后因为精神和身体极度疲惫而放弃，那就毫无意义了。
But micro habits are really, I think, sneaky, amazing way around that, and there's so much fascinating psychology around them. When we set ourselves big and ambitious and sometimes ambiguous goals, like, I don't know, I want to eat healthier or to be more active or fix my anxiety, make new friends, it can be super overwhelming to A, try and stick to it, B, figure out how we're going to achieve that goal through concrete steps, you know, saying something like, I want to make new friends. It's such a scary and daunting goal. Like, how do we actually get there? And I think it's really hard to know when your goal has been achieved. How do you know when you're no longer anxious? How do you know when you're healthier? Like,
但微习惯真的是，我认为，解决这个问题的巧妙、了不起的方法，围绕它们有那么多迷人的心理学。当我们给自己设定宏大、雄心勃勃、有时又模棱两可的目标时，比如，我不知道，我想吃得更健康，或者变得更积极，或者解决我的焦虑，结交新朋友，这可能会让人超级不知所措：A，试着坚持下去；B，弄清楚我们将如何通过具体的步骤来实现这个目标，你知道的，说出类似“我想结交新朋友”这样的话。这是一个非常可怕和令人生畏的目标。我们到底该如何实现它呢？我认为很难知道你的目标何时已经实现。你怎么知道你什么时候不再焦虑了？你怎么知道你什么时候更健康了？就像，
yes, you'll feel it, but how exactly did you get there? If the goal is this big, huge thing that you want and you're pining after and you get there and, you know, how? How do you know, how? How do you know that you could do it again? How can you maintain those lifestyle changes? I think big goals are always going to be really hard to achieve, hence that's saying, you know, if it was easy, everyone would do it. The reason is that they offer require major lifestyle overhaul and changes to our daily habits, which we've become rather attached to. But what if you could achieve those exact same goals by just doing something small every day? That sounds, you know, kind of amazing.
是的，你会感觉到它，但你究竟是如何到达那里的？如果目标是你想要并渴望的这个巨大、宏伟的事情，而你到达了那里，并且，你知道的，怎么做？你怎么知道？你怎么知道你能再次做到？你如何维持这些生活方式的改变？我认为宏大目标总是很难实现的，因此有句俗语说，如果那么容易，每个人都会做。原因在于它们总是需要对我们的日常生活习惯进行重大的生活方式改造和改变，而我们已经对这些习惯产生了一定的依恋。但如果你能通过每天只做一点小事来实现完全相同的目标呢？这听起来，你知道的，有点神奇。
and that's the idea behind micro habits. You are still able to make those big changes, but by making a series of small ones instead. Tasks that are so small and so, you know, convenient that you don't even, you know, notice them half the time and you don't really have an excuse not to do them. And when you keep these small habits up and when you keep these promises to yourself, not only are you able to see progress and reach your goal sustainably, whilst also ensuring that your healthy habits stick,
而这正是微习惯背后的理念。你仍然能够做出那些巨大的改变，但取而代之的是通过一系列微小的改变。这些任务是如此微小，如此，你知道的，方便，以至于你有一半时间甚至都不会注意到它们，而且你真的没有任何借口不去完成它们。当你保持这些小习惯，当你对自己的这些承诺信守不渝时，你不仅能够看到进展并以可持续的方式达成目标，同时还能确保你的健康习惯得以巩固，
but you also gain confidence over time. You know, I think when we set out to achieve big goals and we're really pushing so hard in those first few weeks and those first few months, when we fail or we have a small setback, it can be really easy to see all that progress, to sense that that progress has been undone or to feel a sense of failure.
而且随着时间的推移，你也会重拾自信。你知道的，我认为当我们着手实现宏大的目标，并且在最初的几周和几个月里真的非常努力地推动时，当我们失败或遭遇小挫折时，很容易就会把所有的进展都一笔勾销，觉得那些进展都白费了，或者产生一种失败感。
But micro habits allow us to achieve those goals over time and sustainable. so that we're allowed to have small setbacks as long as we keep up these small habits. So let's talk about some examples. When I was doing this research, and just from my general overall view of how the term micro habits is used, they're often applied to fitness and weight loss and diet culture and physical health, which, of course, I appreciate and I think it's so important that people want to take care of themselves in whatever capacity that might be.
但微习惯允许我们随着时间和可持续性地实现这些目标。这样我们就可以允许自己有小挫折，只要我们保持这些小习惯。那么我们来谈谈一些例子。当我做这项研究时，仅仅从我对微习惯这个词如何被使用的一般整体看法来看，它们经常被应用到健身、减重、饮食文化和身体健康中，当然，我很欣赏这一点，并且我认为人们无论以何种能力想要照顾自己都是非常重要的。
But I kind of want to discuss them in other areas of our lives because I think that although a lot of the time people, especially in our 20s, are really worried about how we look and whether we're active and whether we're physically healthy, sometimes it's not the only focus. And I kind of don't like to talk about that too much on my show. I think it can contribute and easily become a discussion about things that actually are unhealthy and aren't for the best for ourselves.
但我有点想在生活的其他领域讨论它们，因为我认为尽管很多时候人们，特别是在我们20多岁的时候，真的很担心我们的外表、我们是否活跃以及我们的身体是否健康，但有时这并不是唯一的焦点。我有点不想在我的节目中过多地谈论这个。我认为它可能会促成并很容易演变成一场关于那些实际上并不健康且对我们自身并非最好的事情的讨论。
So let's talk about some other areas. For example, if you want to start a podcast, what is a micro habit that can build that? I get people asking me all the time, like, I want to start a podcast. And my first answer is always like, yes, absolutely, you should do it. There is room for everyone. And, you know, you definitely have something to share. And the second question is, and the second kind of statement is always like, how do I do it? A micro habit could be, I don't know, write 300, like write down one idea every day for what you want to talk about on your show or record just one episode a week, even if you only do five minutes each day.
所以让我们谈谈其他领域。例如，如果你想开办一个播客，什么是可以建立这一点的微习惯？经常有人问我类似的问题，比如，我想开办一个播客。我的第一个回答总是：是的，绝对的，你应该去做。这里有每个人的空间。而且，你知道的，你肯定有东西可以分享。第二个问题是，第二种说法总是：我该怎么做？一个微习惯可能是，我不知道，每天写300个字，或者写下一个关于你想在节目中谈论的内容的主意，或者每周只录制一集，即使你每天只做五分钟。
That's a really achievable goal. You know, writing something down in your notes at once a day, some idea that you've had for content or for an episode, it's not going to take too much from you. It's not going to take too much effort and it's really doable. another one that I hear a lot from my friends is spending less time on social media what's the simple micro habit you can do for that you know put your like make a promise to yourself i can go on my phone as much as i want throughout the day but i'm going to put it down at 10 p.m or between the hours of you know every 30 minutes i have to turn my phone off you know for the rest of that half hour into the next until the next hour, just so you have those small breaks or, okay, I want to slowly decrease the
这是一个非常容易实现的目标。你知道的，每天在你的便签里写下一次，一些你对内容或单集的想法，这不会占用你太多时间。它不需要付出太多努力，而且非常可行。我从朋友那里听到的另一个很常见的问题是减少在社交媒体上花的时间。有什么简单的微习惯可以做到这一点？你知道的，把你的——对自己许下承诺：我可以在一天中随意使用手机，但我将在晚上10点放下它，或者在（你知道的）每30分钟之间，我必须把手机关掉，你知道的，在剩下的半小时里直到下一个小时，这样你就可以有这些微小的休息时间，或者，好吧，我想慢慢减少
amount of pickups I have. I don't know. If you have an iPhone, you can see how many times you pick up and you open a social media app like Instagram or TikTok. Say that's like 50 times a day. Be like, okay, by tomorrow I want it to be 49 and then maybe 48 and 47 next week, not even like on a day to day, just trying to think about small things you can do, small goals you can set. Getting over heartbreak, that's a massive topic we talk about on the show because,
我拿起手机的次数。我不知道。如果你有一台iPhone，你可以看到你拿起并打开Instagram或TikTok等社交媒体应用的次数。假设那是每天50次。设定为，好吧，到明天我希望它是49次，然后下周可能是48次和47次，甚至不是按天计算，只是试着考虑你可以做的小事，你可以设定的微小目标。走出心碎的阴影，这是我们在节目中讨论的一个巨大话题，因为，
you know, I think we all've been through that in our 20s and it's often really fucking brutal. How do we, you know, make sure that, how can we apply micro habits to heartbreak? What about just checking their messages less, being like, okay, my only, the only thing I need to do today is to only check to see if they've messaged me once or twice. I can't check it compulsively throughout the day, but I'm still allowed to because I still want to know. Or if you're getting over heartbreak, setting a goal of like, okay, well, I'm going to listen to one song I really, really love and just have like a wild dance, manic singing moment just once a day to make myself feel better.
你知道的，我认为我们20多岁的人都经历过这个，而且通常真的非常残酷。我们如何，你知道的，确保，我们如何将微习惯应用到心碎中？比如少看他们的信息，就像是，好吧，我唯一需要做的事情就是今天只看一两次他们有没有发信息。我不能一整天都强迫性地查看，但我仍然被允许查看，因为我仍然想知道。或者如果你正在走出心碎，设定一个目标，比如，好吧，那我将听一首我真的非常喜欢的歌，每天只需进行一次疯狂的舞蹈、狂热的唱歌时刻，让自己感觉好一点。
Another way that it's, I think micro habits are often applied is productivity and creativity. As we enter into full-time work or we're struggling with uni and we have, you know, jobs, and things to do and bills to pay and relationships to maintain and, I don't know, cleaning, I don't know, whatever you're doing with your life. We're all pretty busy. And sometimes the first thing to go is the things that really fuel our soul, our creative passions and our hobbies. So maybe one of your micro habits, if you're someone who's realizing that they're a little bit disconnected from that creative right side of their brain is to, you know, read just one page of a book each night or simply list five things you're grateful for if you want to get into journaling or,
微习惯通常被应用的另一个领域是生产力和创造力。当我们步入全职工作，或者我们在大学里苦苦挣扎，我们有，你知道的，工作，以及要做的事情、要付的账单、要维系的社交关系，还有，我不知道，打扫卫生，我不知道，无论你的生活在做什么。我们都很忙。有时首先放弃的是那些真正滋养我们灵魂的东西、我们的创作热情和爱好。所以也许你的微习惯之一，如果你意识到自己与右脑的创作部分有点脱节，那就是，你知道的，每晚只读一本书的一页，或者如果你想开始写日记，只需列出五件你感恩的事，或者，
you know, just only, you only need to spend five minutes a day doing like a meditation or a yoga pose or watching a really interesting video that you can contribute to conversations with. Those don't sound too hard, do they? They sound really doable. Everyone has five minutes in their day to do one small thing that might actually make your life a lot better. And over time, these habits build and become bigger and we're able to challenge ourselves to set a new micro habit that actually feels a lot less significant than if we'd started with that step to begin with. Small blocks can still build really big towers and it's harder to take them apart, harder to take that final structure, that final lifestyle that you're looking for apart if those habits that have contributed to it are really easy to do and are really sustainable. So why are we talking about them today? Why are we talking about them in the context of our 20s? I think personally, in our 20s, we have a responsibility to ourselves to decide what kind of lives we want to have.
你知道的，每天只需要花五分钟做冥想、瑜伽姿势，或者观看一个非常有趣的视频，以便你可以为对话做出贡献。这些听起来不是很难，对吧？它们听起来真的很可行。每个人的一天中都有五分钟来做一件可能让你的生活变得更好的小事。随着时间的推移，这些习惯会积累并变得更大，我们能够挑战自己去设定一个新的微习惯，这个微习惯实际上感觉比我们一开始从那个步骤开始时要少得多。小方块仍然可以建造非常高的塔，而且如果促成最终结构的那些习惯非常容易做到并且非常可持续，那么拆除它们、拆除你一直在寻找的最终结构、最终生活方式就会更加困难。那么我们为什么今天要谈论它们呢？为什么我们在20多岁的背景下谈论它们？我认为个人而言，在我们20多岁的时候，我们对自己负有责任，去决定我们想要过什么样的生活。
It's often, I think, when we begin to recognize unhealthy habits or patterns of thinking that might not be the healthiest, that may have come from our upbringing, may have come from our childhood. If you want to listen to the childhood trauma episode, we talk about this a little bit more about how our perspectives and our ways that we see ourselves and the habits that we form really do begin in our early infancy even. But when we get to adulthood, when we get to our 20s, we might want to improve ourselves for the better. We have the emotional and the mental capacity to recognize
这通常是，我认为，当我们开始认识到可能不那么健康的、不健康的习惯或思维模式时，这些模式可能来自我们的成长经历，可能来自我们的童年。如果你想听关于童年创伤的那期节目，我们更多地谈论了我们的视角、我们看待自己的方式以及我们形成的习惯确实甚至从我们的婴儿期就开始了。但当我们步入成年，当我们进入20多岁时，我们可能想要为了更好地改善自己。我们拥有情感和心理能力去认识到
what's not working, to have self-awareness. I feel like many of the people who listen to this show are doing so out of an eagerness to improve themselves, their well-being and their lives or because there's something they're struggling with in their day-to-day lives. Honestly, no matter your circumstances, whatever you're going through right now, implementing these daily micro-habits can actually lead to massive improvements, no matter what area of your life you want to change or improve. One of the micro-habits that I've set myself recently is I found that because I work full-time
什么行不通，去具备自我意识。我觉得收听这个节目的许多人之所以这样做，是因为渴望改善自己、自己的福祉和生活，或者因为他们在日常生活中正挣扎于某些事情。老实说，无论你的情况如何，无论你现在正在经历什么，实施这些日常微习惯实际上都可以带来巨大的改善，无论你想改变或改善你生活的哪个领域。我最近为自己设定的微习惯之一是，我发现因为我做全职工作
and I'm doing this podcast and, you know, I've got to keep up with, you know, my chores and with my friends and trying to be active. The one thing that's kind of fallen off the radar is being physically active and feeling like my body is doing what I want it to do. So I've set this micro habit of like any time I want to go into the office and my office is in the city, I have to walk in. It's a 45 minute walk. It's not that far. It takes like 35 minutes on the office. the train. And that's a really easy habit to implement for me because it's not every day that I have to do it, but it's, and it's really small. It's really doable. And it's really rewarding as well. I think we do often think of physical health when we think of lifestyle change, but it can be so
还要做这个播客，而且，你知道的，我得跟上，你知道的，我的家务，还有我的朋友们，并试图保持活跃。有点被冷落的一件事就是保持身体活跃以及感觉我的身体正在做我希望它做的事情。所以我设定了这个微习惯，比如任何我想去办公室的时候，我的办公室在市区，我都必须走着去。那是45分钟的步行路程。其实没那么远。坐火车去办公室大约需要35分钟。对我来说，这是一个非常容易实施的习惯，因为我不是每天都必须这样做，但是，而且它真的很小。这真的可行。而且这也真的很有回报。我想当我们考虑生活方式的改变时，我们确实经常想到身体健康，但这可以
much more than that. We can use micro habits to reduce anxiety, promote our sleep, be more productive, creative, get over a bad breakup, make more connections. Their beauty is in their simplicity. But also, their universality. They're so easy to integrate into our lives and into really any area of our lives. So let's talk about why they work. I'm really hyping these up today, making them sound like some kind of universal antidote. But there's a reason why micro habits are a lot easier to implement. And I know it sounds intuitive, but there's some stronger science backing it as well. basically they limit how often we can apply an all or nothing mindset and consequently the likelihood of failure. So the all or nothing mindset, it's a way of thinking that kind of relies on extremes
多得多。我们可以用微习惯来减少焦虑、促进睡眠、变得更有成效、更有创造力、走出糟糕的分手、建立更多联系。它们的魅力在于其简单性。但同时，也在于它们的普遍性。它们很容易融入我们的生活，融入我们生活的几乎任何领域。所以让我们谈谈它们为什么管用。我今天真的把这些吹捧得很高，让它们听起来像某种普遍的解药。但微习惯更容易实施是有原因的。我知道这听起来很直观，但它背后也有一些更强有力的科学支持。基本上，它们限制了我们采用非黑即白思维的频率，从而降低了失败的可能性。因此，非黑即白思维是一种
and particularly the extreme of either success or failure. You know, you've got this goal in mind and you're either doing everything completely right. You meet your goal instantly. You're sticking with all of your habits, you're doing everything you need to do perfectly all the time, or you don't do that, you make a slip up, you forget to do something and you fail, you can't go forward, that's done. You know, like it's success or failure and there's nothing in between. All or nothing thinking usually leads to really unrealistic standards for yourself and for others, and it's really hard to maintain motivation because we're humans, we're going to make mistakes, life gets in the way of implementing healthy habits. And this type of thinking, it's known as a
依赖极端的思维方式，特别是成功或失败的极端。你知道的，你心里有这个目标，要么你把所有事情都做得完全正确。你立刻达到了你的目标。你坚持了你所有的习惯，你一直在完美地做你需要做的所有事情，要么你没有做到这一点，你失误了，你忘记做某事，然后你失败了，你无法前行，这就结束了。你知道的，就像要么成功要么失败，中间没有灰色地带。非黑即白思维通常会为你自己和他人设定不切实际的标准，并且很难保持动力，因为我们是人类，我们会犯错，生活会阻碍健康习惯的实施。这种类型的思维，被称为
cognitive distortion, which essentially is an exaggerated pattern of thought and of thinking that derails our progress and can lead us to viewing things in a way that's false to how they truly are. You know, say that one of your goals is like, oh, I want to use social media less and you're being really strict. You're like only an hour a day and that's that. And then. then one day you go over an hour to hour and five minutes and like, well, I've ruined it. I've ruined it. Like, this shows that I don't have self-discipline and I can't meet my goal. And this all-or-nothing distortion is exactly what we're talking about in this instance.
认知扭曲，本质上是一种夸张的思维和思考模式，它会破坏我们的进展，并导致我们以一种与真实情况不符的方式看待事物。你知道的，假设你的目标之一是，哦，我想减少使用社交媒体，而且你非常严格。你觉得每天只有一个小时，就是这样。然后。然后有一天你超过了一个小时，达到了一小时零五分钟，觉得，好吧，我把它搞砸了。我把它搞砸了。就像，这表明我没有自律能力，我无法达到我的目标。这种非黑即白扭曲正是我们在这种情况下所讨论的。
If we engage too frequently in this style of thinking, particularly when we're trying to achieve a goal, it can be really difficult to forgive our failures, to make progress, or feel satisfied and ensure that the goal is sustainable because we're always going to make mistakes. We are, you know, forgetful creatures. We are funny creatures. We're messy creatures. But micro habits, they're able to interrupt that extreme way of thinking, that feedback loop of success or failure. We're able to not only have smaller successes, but teach ourselves that our energy does not need to be 100 million percent committed and tied to one.
如果我们过于频繁地参与这种风格的思考，特别是在我们试图实现目标时，要原谅我们的失败、取得进展、或者感到满足并确保目标是可持续的就会非常困难，因为我们总是会犯错。我们是，你知道的，健忘的生物。我们是滑稽的生物。我们是混乱的生物。但微习惯能够打断那种极端的思考方式，打断成功或失败的反馈循环。我们不仅能够取得较小的成功，还能教导自己，我们的精力不需要百分之百、一千万倍地投入并捆绑在一个
one goal with no slip-ups allowed. They allow us to break things down into smaller bite-sized pieces, which we know are easier for our brains to digest, and they're easier to implement because they require less challenge and less change, and we're more likely to be successful. So the other reason they work is to do with dopamine. I know we talk about dopamine so often on this show, like, all the time, but it's because it's so crucial to so many of our behaviors and our actions and our daily lives. It's like, it is one of the most important neurotransmitters we have in our artillery. Often, the habits we see is being unhealthy. I'm going to use the TikTok example again,
没有任何失误允许的目标上。它们允许我们将事情分解成更容易消化的更小、一口大小的碎片，我们知道这对我们的大脑来说更容易消化，而且更容易实施，因为它们需要的挑战更少，改变更少，我们成功的可能性也更高。所以它们管用的另一个原因与多巴胺有关。我知道我们在节目中经常谈论多巴胺，就像，一直在谈论，但那是因为它对我们的许多行为、行动和日常生活都至关重要。它就像是我们弹药库中最最重要的神经递质之一。通常，我们认为不健康的习惯。我再次使用TikTok的例子，
like scrolling TikTok for hours, TikTok don't assume me, because I'm defaming you or whatever, but, you know, scrolling TikTok for hours before bed or sleeping in or eating food that makes us feel bad, these habits actually bring us some form of dopamine, like we get a dopamine hit or we feel comfortable. So when we attempt to interrupt those habits and overhaul our lives, not only do we prevent activities that our brain actually relies on for dopamine, the chemical that motivates us and creates pleasant feelings and stability, but we also alter our mental comfort space. And that's kind of the area, that's like the things that make our brain feel safe and often routine habits, even if they cause long-term damage, do make us feel safe.
就像在睡觉前刷TikTok几个小时，TikTok不要告我，因为我在诋毁你什么的，但是，你知道的，在睡觉前刷TikTok几个小时，或者睡懒觉，或者吃让我们感觉不舒服的食物，这些习惯实际上给我们带来某种形式的多巴胺，比如我们得到了多巴胺的刺激或者我们感到舒适。因此，当我们试图打断这些习惯并彻底改造我们的生活时，我们不仅阻止了我们的大脑实际依赖多巴胺（这种激发我们动力并产生愉悦感和稳定性的化学物质）的活动，而且我们还改变了我们的精神舒适空间。这有点像那个区域，就像那些让我们的大脑感到安全的事情，通常常规习惯，即使它们造成长期的损害，确实也会让我们感到安全。
And often that causes us to withdraw back into our old habits quicker when we are challenged with other possibly, you know, uncomfortable situations in the external world. I think we see this so often. People set out with big goals, for example, to quit. drinking or stop smoking like cold turkey. But those habits bring comfort and dopamine and serotonin. So as soon as something else challenges us and we no longer have that, you know, that stability that's created by that habit, we're likely to fall straight back into them, you know. But if we say instead of like, I'm going to completely quit drinking and then, you know, you go through a breakup or,
通常这会导致我们在面对外部世界其他可能，你知道的，令人不舒服的情况时，更快地退回到我们的旧习惯中。我想我们经常看到这种情况。人们设定宏大的目标，例如完全戒酒或彻底戒烟。但这些习惯带来了安慰、多巴胺和血清素。因此，一旦其他事情挑战了我们，而我们不再拥有，你知道的，那个由该习惯创造的稳定性，我们很可能会直接回到它们身边，你知道的。但如果我们不说，你知道的，我要彻底戒酒，然后，你知道的，你经历了一次分手或者，
you know, you get a parking fine or you have a shit day at work and suddenly, you know, you're back on it. What if we instead said, you know, I'm going to drink one less drink than I normally would on a night out, or I'm only going to drink drinks with lower levels of alcohol, or only drink one to two days a week. We give our brains time to adapt to these new habits, which makes them easier and our goals more sustainable while still giving ourselves the comfort that something we enjoy might provide. So how do we implement these? How do we implement micro habits?
你知道的，你拿到了一张停车罚单，或者你在工作中有糟糕的一天，突然间，你知道的，你又回去了。如果我们不说那样的话，而是说，你知道的，我要比平时在外面玩的时候少喝一杯，或者我只喝酒精含量较低的饮料，或者每周只喝一到两天。我们给大脑时间来适应这些新习惯，这使它们更容易养成，也使我们的目标更具可持续性，同时仍然给自己提供某种我们享受的东西可能带来的安慰。那么我们如何实施这些？我们如何实施微习惯？
I think often when we have a big goal, we are not particularly patient and we want to reach it right now. We're like, okay, I've decided I want to be fit and healthy. So I want to be able to run a marathon in like five days. And that's so sexy and like fast results are exciting and we want them right now, especially in, you know, the modern world where we can get things that we want so easily. But trust me, doing small, boring things. gets the job done much more sustainably and much more reliably because of all of those reasons that we've talked about you know it doesn't leave us completely devoid of the dopamine attached our old
我认为通常当我们有一个宏大的目标时，我们并不是特别有耐心，我们希望现在就实现它。我们就像，好吧，我决定我要变得健康。所以我想在大概五天内跑完一场马拉松。这太性感了，而且快速的结果令人兴奋，我们现在就想要它们，尤其是在，你知道的，现代社会中，我们可以如此轻易地得到我们想要的东西。但相信我，做一些微小的、无聊的事情。能够以更可持续、更可靠的方式完成工作，因为我们讨论过的所有这些原因，你知道的，它不会让我们完全失去依附于旧习惯的多巴胺
habits they prevent us from having that all or nothing thinking they're easier to implement into our lives they cause less disruption but i think that it's important to also have a sense of balance here and not go overboard with the micro habits you know what i mean because then essentially essentially you're doing exactly what you would have done if you'd done that all or nothing thinking and were completely committed to a goal. It's probably best to not have more than three to five. You know, your three might be, I'm going to drink one extra glass of water a day. I'm going to wake up 30 minutes earlier and I'm going to read one page of a book at night. So simple. But if you're like, I'm going to read one page of a book at night, I'm going to eat an extra serve of vegetables and I'm going to
习惯，它们阻止我们产生那种非黑即白的思维，它们更容易融入我们的生活，它们引起的干扰更少，但我认为在这里保持一种平衡感也很重要，不要对微习惯操之过急，你知道我的意思吗？因为那样的话，本质上你所做的就和你采取非黑即白思维并完全致力于某个目标时所做的一模一样。最好不要超过三到五个。你知道的，你的三个可能是，我每天要多喝一杯水。我要早醒30分钟，晚上读一页书。就是这么简单。但如果你觉得，我要晚上读一页书，我要多吃一份蔬菜，我要
wake up at 7.30 instead of at 8. And I'm also going to call one friend every single day. And I'm also going to do 100 million things. Firstly, that just sounds really hard to keep track of. But also, you know, yeah, you're not going to be able to keep up. And it's going to become really mentally exhausting. And you're probably going to have more failures and successes. So try and make it easier for yourself. And just choose three to five, five, like five even is probably a few, too many. But maybe just three, that target things you really want to change in your life. And I think once you start implementing those little practices every single day, those series of small wins and those confidence boosters that you give yourself
在7:30而不是8点醒来。而且我还要每天给一个朋友打电话。而且我还要做一千万件事情。首先，这听起来只是很难跟踪。而且，你知道的，是的，你无法坚持下去。这会让人在精神上精疲力竭。而且你可能会经历比成功更多的失败。所以试着让自己轻松一点。只要选择三到五个，五个——甚至五个可能也有点太多了。但也许只需三个，针对你真正想要改变生活的事情。我认为一旦你开始每天实施这些小实践，那些一系列的小胜利以及你给自己的自信心提升
allows you to build momentum and allows you to sustainably get to the goal that you ultimately want at the end of the day. It might take a little bit longer. You're still going to get there. You have time. And when you do get there, it's going to be sustainable. Thank you so much for listening. This was such a fun episode. It was a shorter one, but I was like, this is so fascinating to me. And I think such an important ritual and idea to implement into our lives, especially in our 20s when we're trying to construct the lifestyle that we want to lead and we're trying to, you know, fix things that may have gone wrong in childhood and fix unhealthy habits that we might have. So I really hope that if this is something you're considering, You give it a go. You try it out and see what happens.
就能让你建立起势头，并可持续地达到你最终在一天结束时真正想要的目标。这可能会稍微花点时间。你仍然会到达那里。你有时间。当你到达那里时，它将是可持续的。非常感谢你们的收听。这真是个有趣的单集。这是一个较短的节目，但我觉得，这对我和我来说太迷人了。我认为这也是一个非常重要的仪式和理念，可以融入我们的生活，特别是在我们20多岁的时候，当我们试图构建我们想要过的生活方式，并且试图，你知道的，修复童年可能出错的事情，修复我们可能有的不健康习惯。所以我真的希望如果这是你正在考虑的事情，你会去尝试一下。尝试一下，看看会发生什么。
You know, you really don't have anything to lose. And they're so easy. You know, my God, I sound like this is some, like, micro habits. There's like a brand that's like sponsoring me. I swear, it's like, I just think it's a great idea. And hopefully you do too. Before we wrap up, I do just want to say a huge thank you again for subscribing for bonus content. You really allow me to do what I love.
你知道的，你真的没有什么可失去的。而且它们太简单了。你知道的，天哪，听起来这好像是某个，比如微习惯。有什么品牌在赞助我一样。我发誓，就像，我只是觉得这是一个绝佳的主意。希望你也这么觉得。在结束之前，我只想再次向你们表达诚挚的谢意，感谢你们订阅付费内容。你们真的让我能够做我所爱的事情，
and that is such a huge privilege. Like it's crazy. So I want to thank you so much. And I hope that you continue to support the show and you continue to love the content that we're putting out. Well, I don't know why I say we. It's only me. And if you have any feedback, if you have any suggestions for episodes, shoot me a message on Instagram.
而这真的是一种巨大的特权。就像这太疯狂了。所以我想非常感谢你们。我希望你们能继续支持这个节目，并继续喜爱我们发布的内容。好吧，我不知道我为什么要说“我们”。只有我一个人。如果你有任何反馈，如果你对单集有任何建议，在Instagram上给我发个消息。
I love hearing from you. And hopefully I can do them. And yeah, let me know what you think of the show. leave it a five-star rating on Spotify if you get the chance and if you feel cool to do so. And thank you again for listening. I will see you in our main episode for this week, which is why rejection stings. Thank you so much. Have a lovely, lovely day.
我喜欢听到你们的声音。希望我能做到。是的，让我知道你对节目的看法。如果有机会并且你觉得很酷的话，在Spotify上给它留一个五星评价。再次感谢你们的收听。我们将在本周的主节目中见，主题是“为什么拒绝会刺痛”。非常感谢。祝你有美好、美好的一天。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《回看往事》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个大时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're, you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
这是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它，在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难学步》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我篡改测试一次。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。此剧集尚无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。